and are you ready for this performance  oh oh yes we are ready and so excited so  excited how does that feel to know that  you could walk away tonight being an  Oscar winner you know I I have it I  haven't really been able to fully  process that you know it's one of those  things you just never know what's going  to happen and the truth is I'm just  happy to be here in the presence of such  incredible artists I mean so much talent  in this room and it's been my dream  since I was a little girl that I would  be able to even you know work as an  actress to work as a musician to make it  in this world and I just I can't believe  that I'm here and I'm so very happy and  my whole family is here with me is  everybody  I said Bradley not that nervous about  tonight he's calm collect everybody  saying oh yeah he's chillin  [Laughter]  you  [Music]